>> AS WE AWAIT THE FURTHER
RESULTS OUT OF THOSE STATES,
ARIZONA AND CALIFORNIA, WE KNOW
WHAT'S HAPPENING IN THE SENATE.
CNN HAS PROJECTED DEMOCRATS WILL
MAINTAIN CONTROL OF THE SENATE
DEFYING GOP EXPECTATIONS OF A
RED WAVE.
JOINING US NOW IS SENATE
MAJORITY LEADER CHUCK SCHUMER OF
NEW YORK WHO WON HIS ELECTION
AND NOW SET TO BECOME NEW YORK'S
LONGEST SERVING SENATOR IN HIS
FIFTH TERM.
YOU WERE MAINTAINING THAT TITLE
OF SENATE MAJORITY LEADER.
YOU'RE FACING HISTORICAL ODDS,
INFLATION AT A HIGH, BIDEN'S
APPROVAL RATING IS NOT.
HOW DO DEMOCRATS DEFY THOSE
EXPEC
EXPECTATIONS?
>> I SAY THERE ARE THREE REASONS
WE DEFIED ALL THE EXPECTATIONS.
FIRST, WE HAD GREAT CANDIDATES.
OUR CANDIDATES CARED ABOUT
PEOPLE, WERE EFFECTIVE, TALKED
DIRECTLY TO EVERYDAY AMERICANS'
CONCERNS, AND THEY RAN AGAINST A
WHOLE BUNCH OF FLAWED CANDIDATES
WHO WERE INTERESTED IN TOSSING
FIRE BOMBS ACROSS THE WALL BUT
NOT REALLY GETTING THINGS DONE
FOR AVERAGE FAMILIES.
THE SECOND REASON WE RON, OUR
RECORD OF ACCOMPLISHMENT.
WE ACCOMPLISHED SO MUCH FOR
AVERAGE FOLKS.
THEY NEVER THOUGHT WE WOULD BE
ABLE TO TAKE ON PHARMA AND GET
PRESCRIPTION DRUG PRICES LOWER.
THEY NEVER THOUGHT WE COULD DO
ANYTHING ON CLIMATE CHANGE.
WE DID THE MOST EFFECTIVE THING
WE'VE EVER DONE ON CLIMATE
CHANGE.
ON DIFFICULT ISSUES EVEN LIKE
GUN SAFETY, WE CAME TOGETHER
WITH REPUBLICANS ON A BIPARTISAN
COMPROMISE AND MOVED THE BALL
FORWARD FOR THE FIRST TIME IN 30
YEARS.
DEMOCRATS GOT A LOT DONE.
TO AVERAGE VOTERS, THEY CARE
ABOUT THAT.
I KNOW THERE'S A LOT OF STERM
AND DRANG HERE, BUT THEY CARED.
THIRD AND MAYBE THE MOST
IMPORTANT, THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
SAW THAT DEMOCRACY WAS AT RISK.
THEY SAW THERE WERE THESE MAGA
REPUBLICANS WHO DENIED THE
ELECTION.
THAT'S ONE OF THE FUNDAMENTALS
OF DEMOCRACY.
WHEN YOU LOSE AN ELECTION, YOU
DON'T SAY THE ELECTION WAS A
FRAUD AND YOU CALL IT OFF, WHO
EITHER IGNORED VIOLENCE OR EVEN
ENCOURAGED IT WHEN THE MAGA
REPUBLICANS DID IT.
THE REPUBLICAN LEADERSHIP IS TO
BLAME HERE BECAUSE THEY DIDN'T
PUSH BACK.
THE AVERAGE AMERICAN SAW THIS.
THEY SAW THAT AUTOCRACY WAS
ERODING THE EDGE OF OUR
DEMOCRACY, AND WE GOT VOTES FROM
REPUBLICANS WHO SAID THIS NEW
MAGA REPUBLICAN PARTY LED BY
TRUMP -- I'M A REAGAN
REPUBLICAN, I'M A BUSH
REPUBLICAN, I'M NOT THIS TYPE OF
REPUBLICAN.
THAT MADE A HUGE DIFFERENCE AS
WELL.
IF YOU LOOK FINALLY AT THE
CLOSING ARGUMENTS SAY IN NEVADA,
ONE OF THE TWO CLOSING ARMGTS
FOR KATHERINE CORTEZ MASSTO WAS
THIS IDEA THAT HER OPPONENT WAS
AN ELECTION DENIER.
THE SECOND, OF COURSE, WAS
CHOICE WHICH WAS AN IMPORTANT
ISSUE BOTH IN ITSELF.
AMERICAN PEOPLE DO NOT WANT TO
SEE RIGHTS AE ROADED.
MY CHILDREN, MY DAUGHTERS WILL
HAVE FEWER RIGHTS THAN MY WIFE
OR MY MOM DID UNDER THIS.
BUT IT ALSO SHOWED HOW FAR RIGHT
THIS REPUBLICAN PARTY HAD MOVED,
AND THE REPUBLICAN LEADERSHIP
WAS LETTING IT HAPPEN.
>> WE WANT TO BREAK DOWN THE GOP
ASPECT OF THIS.
YOU HAVE A LOT TO DO -- I KNOW
YOU'RE COMING BACK TO WASHINGTON
AFTER THIS INTERVIEW.
>> GETTING IN THE CAR.
>> YOU HAVE A LOT ON YOUR
AGENDA.
ARE YOU GOING TO TALK TO MITCH
McCONNELL?
WHAT DOES THAT LOOK LIKE?
>> LET ME JUST SAY THIS.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE YEARNING
FOR US TO GET THINGS DONE.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, THEY
BELIEVE IN DEMOCRACY.
I WANT TO FINISH THAT LAST
POINT.
THE ROOTS OF DEMOCRACY ARE A LOT
WORRIERS GIVE IT CREDIT FOR.
THEY UNDERSTOOD DEMOCRACY WAS
BEING ERODED.
THEY ALSO ARE PRACTICAL.
THEY WANT US TO GET SOMETHING
DONE FOR THEM.
THEY DON'T EXPECT US TO DO
EVERYTHING AT ONCE.
THEY WANT US TO GET SOMETHING
DONE.
THAT'S WHY I THINK SO MANY OF
THEM CHOSE DEMOCRATS OVER
REPUBLICANS BECAUSE WE WERE
FOCUSING ON WHAT THEY CARED
ABOUT AND WHAT THEY NEEDED AS
OPPOSED TO TOSSING THESE HAND
GRENADES ACROSS THE WALL.
I WILL SAY TO MY PARTY, WE'RE
NOT GOING TO GET EVERYTHING WE
WANT LIKE ON THE GUNS BILL, WE
DIDN'T GET EVERYTHING WE WANT.
LET'S TRY TO SIT DOWN WITH THE
REPUBLICANS AND GET SOMETHING
DONE.
AND JUST AS IMPORTANTLY, I'M
GOING TO SAY TO THE REPUBLICANS
IN THE SENATE WHO ARE NOT THE
MAGA REPUBLICANS, STOP LETTING
THEM LEAD YOUR PARTY.
WORK WITH US TO GET THINGS DONE,
AND I INTEND TO SIT DOWN WITH
MITCH McCONNELL --
>> YOU'VE BEEN SAYING THAT -- GO
AHEAD.
>> YOU'RE SITTING DOWN WITH
MITCH McCONNELL THIS WEEK?
>> I INTEND -- I SAID THIS
YESTERDAY AND THE DAY BEFORE,
TOO.
I INTEND TO SIT DOWN WITH HIM
AND SAY WE SHOULD BE WORKING
TOGETHER.
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO GET THE
EXTREMISTS IN YOUR PARTY TO WORK
WITH ANYBODY, BUT THE REST OF US
CAN WORK TOGETHER AND GET SOME
REAL THINGS DONE FOR THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
IN ANSWER TO YOUR QUESTION, DON,
WE GOT PLENTY --
>> YOU THINK IT'S GOING TO WORK
THIS TIME?
>> IN THE LAST SENATE WHERE WE
GOT SO MUCH CREDIT IN JUNE, JULY
AND AUGUST FORGETTING THINGS
DONE, FIVE OF THOSE SIX BILLS
WERE BIPARTISAN.
THE GUNS BILL WAS BIPARTISAN.
THE BILL TO HELP OUR VETERANS
EXPOSED TO THE TOXINS THAT CAME
OUT OF THE BURN PITS WAS
BIPARTISAN.
THE MOST MAJOR INDUSTRIAL POLICY
BILL EVER OR IN A VERY LONG
TIME, THE CHIPS AND SCIENCE BILL
WAS BIPARTISAN.
WE DID MOST OF OUR -- I TRIED TO
DO THINGS IN A BIPARTISAN WAY,
AND WE'VE HAD --
>> I UNDERSTAND WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING.
YOU'VE HAD LOTS OF SUCCESS.
I'M WONDERING WHAT IS
DIFFERENT -- WHAT IS GOING TO BE
DIFFERENT THIS TIME WITH THE
MAGA REPUBLICANS?
YOU SAID THAT BEFORE, PLEASE
WORK WITH US.
WHY IS IT DIFFERENT THIS TIME?
>> IT'S DIFFERENT THIS TIME
BECAUSE THEY LOST.
THEY ALL EXPECTED TO WIN.
THE RED WAVE PROVED TO BE A RED
MIRAGE.
ONE OF THE MAIN REASONS FOR SURE
WAS THAT AVERAGE AMERICAN FOLKS,
EVEN THOSE IN THE MIDDLE, EVEN
THOSE WHO TENDED TO BE
REPUBLICAN SAID I'M AFRAID OF
THIS MAGA.
THEY'RE TRYING TO RUIN OUR
DEMOCRACY.
IT'S NOT -- IF YOU LOOK AT THE
NUMBERS, IF YOU LOOK AT THE
RESULTS, HOUSE AND SENATE, THE
MAGA REPUBLICAN WAY DIDN'T WORK.
THE MAGA REPUBLICAN CANDIDATES
ACROSS THE BOARD, YOU JUST
SHOWED SOME OF THEM, LOST.
IF YOU'RE A GOOD LEADER OF A
REPUBLICAN PARTY, YOU SAY
CONTINUING TO FOLLOW THEM IS A
PATH TO DISASTER.
>> ONE MORE FOLLOWUP TO THAT.
>> SURE.
>> THE MESSAGING.
PEOPLE WERE VERY CRITICAL OF THE
MESSAGING AS YOU SAW IN THE
MEDIA.
I STALKED TO A COUPLE OF FOLKS
IN THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY THIS
WEEK EN.
ONE IS AN ADVISOR TO THE
PRESIDENT.
HE SAID I WAS TELLING THE POTUS
THE ENTIRE TIME THAT THE STREETS
WERE NOT SAYING WHAT THE POLLS
WERE SAYING AND THAT YOUNG
PEOPLE ARE COMING OUT.
THEY'RE TELLING ME RATHER THAN
HAVING BIG EVENTS AND SAYING THE
PRESIDENT ISN'T GOING HERE OR
THERE, THAT YOU ACTUALLY HAD
DEMOCRATS IN THE TRENCHES IN
AREAS WORKING WITH PEOPLE,
TALKING ABOUT THE
ACCOMPLISHMENTS, ASKING THEM
WHAT THEY WERE GOING TO DO AND
THE PUNDITS AND THE MEDIA DIDN'T
UNDERSTAND THE STRATEGY.
>> CORRECT.
IF YOU WOULD HAVE LOOKED AT WHAT
ACTUALLY WAS HAPPENING AS
OPPOSED TO THE DAY TO DAY,
WHAT'S THE LATEST FIRE BOMB
THEY'RE THROWING OVER THE WALL,
YOU WOULD HAVE SEEN JUST WHAT
YOU SAID, THAT WE WERE TALKING
TO AVERAGE PEOPLE.
YOU KNOW WHAT ONE OF OUR MOST
SUCCESSFUL COMMERCIALS AND
ARGUMENTS WAS?
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS.
WE WERE GETTING THE COST OF
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS LOW.
WHEN YOU POLL THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE OVER THE LAST FIVE, TEN
YEARS, WHAT'S ONE OF THE NUMBER
ONE OR TWO OR THREE THINGS THEY
WANT?
GET THE COST OF THOSE DRUGS
DOWN.
WE DID IT.
WE DID IT IN THE IRA BILL.
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT YOUNG
PEOPLE, I PREDICTED THE YOUNG
PEOPLE WERE GOING TO VOTE FOR
US.
WHY?
WE FOCUSED ON CLIMATE WHICH THEY
REALLY CARE ABOUT, AND WE GOT
MORE DONE FOR CLIMATE THAN EVER
IN HISTORY, AND WE TALKED ABOUT
STUDENT DEBT.
YOU KNOW, AGAIN, A LOT OF THE
PUNDITS SAID -- THE YOUNG
PEOPLE, WHEN I WOULD GO TO A
GROUP OF YOUNG PEOPLE, WHEN I
WOULD GO TO A BLACK CHURCH, THE
NUMBER ONE THING I'D BE ASKED IS
WHAT ABOUT STUDENT DEBT?
WE DID SOMETHING ABOUT IT.
>> FAIR.
BUT NOW A FEDERAL JUDGE HAS SAID
YOU OVERSTEPPED
CONSTITUTIONALLY.
>> WELL --
>> THAT MATTERS FOR MILLIONS --
IT MATTERS FOR THE MILLIONS OF
PEOPLE WHO BET ON THIS
ADMINISTRATION AND THE FACT YOU
DIDN'T DO IT LEGISLATIVELY, YOU
DID IT THROUGH EXECUTIVE ORDER.
>> A MAGA REPUBLICAN JUDGE, AND
WHAT WE HAVE DONE IN THIS SENATE
IS PASSED A RECORD AMOUNT OF
JUDGES AT THE DISTRICT COURT.
>> YES, YOU HAVE.
THERE HAS BEEN A LOT OF
MOVEMENT.
>> AND THE COURT OF APPEALS TO
COUNTERBALANCE THESE MAGA JUDGES
WHICH THE PUBLIC DOESN'T LIKE.
NOW THAT WE HAVE THE MAJORITY,
WE'LL BE ABLE TO KEEP DOING IT.